Chief minister was on her IG recently digitally laid the
foundation stone of new plant of ultra tech cement factory
in balara village of Poly district.
From her office in jeopardy on this occasion chairman of
other debril industries group Kumar mangalam birla and managing director
of the company KK maheshwary were also present seomra just
said rajastan is the biggest producer of cement in the
country.
By setting up a Ford plant thousands of direct and
indirect employment opportunities will be available to the youth of
the Poly district the government will try to provide all
necessary infrastructures as early as possible so that the production
the plant starts quickly.